-It's time to play
a game of deception
called "True Confessions."
♪♪
Now, my first opponent tonight
is an American legend
and country music icon.
Please welcome Dolly Parton.
-Hi.
-Look at you.
Oh, you are the best.
Oh, Dolly, thank you so much
for being here.
Dolly and I will be facing off
against a very talented actor
who stars in the new movie
"To All The Boys:
Always and Forever."
Give it up for Noah Centineo.
-Oh! Ooh, wow.
You're already playing
the game, I see.
You got your game face.
-We're in it.
-All right,
here's how this works.
Each of us have two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true, the other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other players will
interrogate you,
and they have to come to
a unanimous decision.
Is it a truth, or is it a lie?
Dolly, you will go first.
Noah, which envelope
should she open,
number one or number two?
-Hmm.
Let's go number one.
-Yeah, I'm feeling that, too.
-This one?
-Yep, I'm feeling that, too.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
-All right.
Here I go.
Oh, Lordy, I'm, like,
at the Academy Awards.
Can't get it
out of the deal here.
Okay, sorry.
-[ Laughs ]
-I dated a guy, and he kicked me
out of a car
and made me walk home at night
through a forest
with bears and bobcats.
-[ Laughing ] What?
All right. Wait a second.
All right.
-[ Laughs ]
-What year?
Do you remember --
What year was this?
-Oh, I was a teenager.
I was about --
Oh, I was 17, 18 years old.
-Okay, 17.
-Did you encounter bears
and bobcats,
or were they just present?
-Absolutely.
-Good question.
-I heard them, felt them.
-Do you remember
what car it was?
-Well, I know it was
a really good car,
'cause I had a date with a boy,
and I only dated him
because he had a car.
-[ Laughs ]
-And so it was a nice car.
I think it was a Chevy,
maybe a '57.
Something like that.
-Why did he kick you
out of the car?
What was the thing
that happened?
-Well, it was a "put out
or get out," uh, situation.
-Ah. You stepped.
-So he kicked me out,
told me to walk home.
-And you stepped.
I like that.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Put out or get out.
-Where was this forest?
-Well, this was up in
The Smoky Mountains
of East Tennessee,
and we were about five miles
from my home,
and that's way back
in the mountains,
I mean, where there are bears
and bobcats.
And there are those toothless
"Deliverance"
kind of mountain men,
in addition to
the bears and all that.
-Yeah, the bears
don't even have teeth.
-That was not
a pleasant place to be.
-Noah, I don't know.
Dolly is also --
Not only is she a talented
singer and songwriter,
but she's also
a very good actor.
So I don't know if this is --
she could be playing us
like a fiddle.
-I'm feeling like
I'm being played,
to be honest with you.
-But I also feel like Dolly
is very strong,
and she would do something
like that.
Like, yeah.
-Oh, absolutely.
I think it's -- honest,
I think she's telling the truth.
-Gosh. I'm going to say, yes,
it's true.
-It is true!
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh.
-No way.
-I swear it's true.
But I did learn something
that night, though.
I thought, if that ever happens
to me again,
I'm definitely giving it up.
[ Laughter ]
I would rather be --
I would rather be
chewed on by a boy
than a bear.
And so I thought that --
-Oh, my gosh.
You are the best.
-Okay. It is my turn.
Which envelope should I open,
number one or number two?
Dolly?
-Dolly, go ahead.
-I think number two.
-Okay.
Do do do do-doo. Okay.
I was at a party
at someone's house,
and I heard Jeff Bezos say,
"Alexa, who's your daddy?"
[ Laughter ]
-Do you remember
what Alexa said in return?
-Uh, I don't know
if she answered.
I just thought
it was just bizarre
that I could not --
I can't believe Jeff Bezos,
why would he --
that he would just lean in --
He didn't even know I was there,
I don't think.
He just kind of leaned in
and just said it to Alexa.
And I was like,
"Did I just see that?"
-So, wait. Did he whisper it?
It was like a -- It was like a
gentle, like, whisper to Alexa?
-No he didn't whisper
"Who's your daddy?"
But he just kinda --
No, he said out loud.
I think he -- I think he knew...
Yeah, he knew that he was
being funny, probably.
-Do you use Alexa a lot?
Are you one of those people
that really do all that,
ask all these crazy things
and ask for jokes
and all these weird people?
-I do. I use it all the time.
I talk to --
But this is just weird,
random at a party,
and I just saw it happen,
and it's almost --
It's, like, rare that you
would ever see
the guy who invented Alexa
say to Alexa,
"Who's your daddy?"
-And what was he wearing?
What was -- What was Bezos
wearing?
-Wearing almost
this exact same outfit.
I am dressed like Jeff Bezos
from that --
[ Laughter ]
I'm wearing the Jeff Bezos line
of suits. Yeah.
-Well, it is time for us
to say that's a lie?
-A lie, too.
-[ Laughs ]
I think that's a lie.
-It is the truth.
-Is it really?
-What?
-Oh, okay.
-And I was like, "What?!"
That is something
I will never ever forget, ever.
It is a true story.
-I guess not.
Well, that's a good one.
I thought that was a lie.
-Okay.
-That's incredible.
-We've got two truths now.
-Yeah, here we go.
-Let's see what --
-Oh, interesting.
You're right.
Noah, now it is your turn.
Dolly, which envelope
should he open,
number one or number two?
-I think number one.
-Yup, number one.
-All right.
-Yeah.
In honor of all Dolly's songs.
Number one.
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
-I want to make this
a little dramatic.
-[ Chuckling ] Oh, my goodness.
Wow.
-Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's really --
-I once locked my father
in a meat locker for two hours
before telling someone.
-Why did you wait so long
if you accidentally did it?
-I was 9 years old,
and I-I panicked.
And, like,
I tried to get him out,
and then we were on a tour,
and so --
-A tour of a meat locker?
-Well, no,
it was a meat facility.
He owned, like,
a restaurant back then.
And so we were looking
at different, like, meats
and stuff.
And he took me on it,
but it was with a group
of, like, all of his members.
And so --
-Were you the only
9-year-old there,
or was it a bunch of kids
going around a meat locker?
-No, no, I was the only one.
I was the only one.
-Did you get along
with your father?
Did you like him?
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Oh, okay.
I just wanted to make sure
that you weren't trying to
really get rid of him.
-Was some part of you
kind of excited
that you did lock your dad --
How did you know
that he was locked in there?
-That's what I --
[ Laughs ]
-He went in there,
and I closed the door.
And then I realized that it
locks from the outside,
but I didn't know
how to unlock it.
And I was embarrassed to,
like, go and tell someone
that I had locked him in there.
-How long was your dad
in the meat locker?
-[ Laughing ] For two hours.
-What?! No, no.
-Was he, like, frozen?
Did it, like,
make him sick or what?
-No, they're not that cold.
Like --
-That's a good story.
Whether it's a truth or a lie,
that's an amazing story.
-Oh, no.
-It's scary. Wow.
-I'm baffled, Dolly.
What do you think?
I'm torn, because --
-I think --
I kind of think
that might be true.
-I think it's a lie.
I think he's playing us.
I think he did
the sheet over his head.
He made the story up.
And he's an actor.
I'm going to say it's a lie.
-It's a lie. Yeah, it's a lie.
-Yes! Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that was
a good one, though.
-That was not bad, dude.
We got a true confession.
-That was very good.
-My thanks to Dolly Parton
and Noah Centineo.